[Music]
air raid sirens sound in the ukrainian
capital kiev as the president
volatilized says a full-scale russian
invasion is underway
said his country was being attacked and
urged people not to panic as reports of
explosions came in from cities across
ukraine
russian president vladimir putin has
tried to justify the decision to send in
troops by saying it is a life-and-death
decision for the future of russia
the attack on his neighbor has drawn
international outrage
russia has launched a military assault
on ukraine hitting targets across the
country u.s president joe biden has
condemned the attack as unjustified and
unprovoked here in germany chancellor
olaf schultz said it was a terrible day
for ukraine in a dark day for europe
russian president vladimir putin
announced the move in an unscheduled
television address shortly before 6 a.m
moscow time he warned the world that any
attempt to interfere would lead to quote
consequences you've never seen
within minutes explosions were reported
in cities around ukraine including
odessa kharkiv kramatorsk
ukrainian leader vladimir zelinsky said
it was a full-scale invasion and that
russia was attacking military
infrastructure throughout the country
and border
he used uh guards
not to urge citizens not to panic and
told them to stay indoors our political
correspondent thomas sparrow is with me
here in the studio thomas uh talk us
through what we know so far well very
tense moments in ukraine very tense
moments as well in europe some of the
images that we are just seeing there on
on the screen that we've just seen there
on the screen although they are
unverified they are reportedly of
attacks that are happening in the
eastern part of ukraine in particular
some experts and some analysts
mentioning that it could be military
targets in in particular that have been
first targeted by by this attack
but it's still all very unclear in
general very unclear on the one hand
about what is happening in the eastern
part of of ukraine also very unclear as
to what the motivations are behind this
and what the reaction will be so it's
all
very much developing both on the ground
with those images that we that we see
but also with the political reaction
that we'll hear from european capitals
and also from washington what's going to
happen now from a political perspective
is
first a lot of very stark reactions very
deep warnings we've seen that already
from some of the political leaders
calling it a dark hour for europe one of
the most difficult moments since world
war ii and then what steps can be taken
beyond those words
one step that is expected
by analysts is further sanctions towards
russia that could hit the financial
infrastructure even more related to
russia's
energy sector also when it comes to
banking the swift uh the swift mechanism
it's interest it will be important to
see
what they agree these leaders when they
meet for example under the g7 format or
under the sort of a nato meeting or even
a european union leader meeting so this
is what we'll see coming up next a
political reaction which has come after
these images that we're seeing that are
that i'm a stress are still unverified
okay so we're uh we of course are
expecting severe
sanctions to be imposed on russia as a
result of this attack on ukraine uh we
were just looking at some pictures there
of some smoke rising above a city of
course these are unconfirmed reports but
we're hearing uh reports of fighting
around the country stay with us thomas
we're going to cross now to our
correspondent in uh in brussels i'm told
we have alexander from nahman who is uh
standing by as we wait for that address
from the european commission president
ursula fonda lyon
so what can we expect uh alexandra from
the uh from this speech how is europe
going to react
warzola fonda line the commission
president will be i i think the first
senior figure to address a
reporter's
life this morning and in a statement
issued earlier today
she already made clear that the european
union is going to impose massive and
severe sanctions in response
to
what the european union is describing as
an unprecedented and unprovoked
military aggression by russia and we
know that the european commission has
been working on
those sanctions for a while now we
saw the european union imposing the
first
trench of sanctions already on tuesday
but it was clear that they are prepared
to impose more sanctions um if russia
invades ukraine and now i guess we are
going to hear from ozola fonder lion
more about that and uh we are expecting
the european union to impose sanctions
against
whole
sectors of russia's industry russia's
energy sector sanctions against
the russian elite russian oligarchs
you just spoke with our colleague in the
studio about the swift system
that is also what is expected that the
europeans together with the u.s and with
the uk uh would move forward to cut off
russia from
the electronic payments system swift
alexandra you've been following this of
course all along the news uh the
announcement by vladimir putin that in a
that an attack on ukraine was about to
take place came through here just about
four and a half hours ago i understand
that ursula fonda line is approaching
the podium is about to give her address
we're going to cut over straight now to
that press conference
sovereign country
and once again in the center of europe
innocent women men and children are
dying
of fear for their lives
we condemn this barbaric attack
and the cynical arguments to justify it
it is president putin
who is bringing war back to europe
and in these dark hours
the european union and its people
stand by ukraine and its people
we are facing
an unprecedented act of aggression
by the russian leadership against a
sovereign independent country
russian's target is not only donbass
the target is not only ukraine
the target is the stability in europe
and the whole of the international peace
order
and we will hold president putin
accountable for that
later today we will present a package of
massive and targeted sanctions
to european leaders for approval
with this package
we will target strategic sectors of the
russian economy
by blocking their access
to technologies and markets that are key
for russia
we will weaken russia's economic base
and its capacity to modernize
and in addition we will freeze russian
assets in the european union
and stop the access
of russian banks to european financial
financial markets
like with the first package of sanctions
we are closely aligned
with our partners and allies the united
states the united kingdom canada but
also for example japan and australia
these sanctions are designed to take a
heavy toll
on the kremlin's interests
and their ability to finance war
and we know that millions of russians do
not want war
president putin is trying to turn the
clock back to the times
of the russian empire
but in doing so
he is putting at risk the future of the
russian
people i call on russia to immediately
stop the violence
and to withdraw its troops from
ukraine's territory
we will not let president putin tear
down the security architecture
that has given europe peace and
stability over many decades
we will not allow president putin to
replace place the rule of law
by the rule of force and ruthlessness
he should not underestimate
the resolve and strength of our
democracies
and history has proven
that societies and alliances build on
trust
and freedom
are resilient and successful and that's
exactly what the autocrats fear
the european union stands with ukraine
and its people
we will continue to support them
ukraine will prevail
thank you
these are
among the darkest hour
for europe since the end of world war ii
a major nuclear power
has attacked
a neighbor country
and is threatening reprisals
of any other states
that may come to its rescue
this is not only the greatest violation
of international law
it's a violation of the basic principles
of human coexistence
it's costing many lives
with unknown consequences
ahead of us
the european union
will respond in the strongest possible
terms
president of the european council
president michel has called for a
meeting of the european council this
evening
and they will agree and provide
political guidance
to adopt
the stronger package
the harshest package of sanctions we
have ever implemented
as high representative for the foreign
affairs and security policy of the
european union
i will be in touch with our partners
around the world
to ensure the international community
will be
fully
grasping the gravity of the moment
and to call strongly
and united on russia to seize
immediately this behavior intolerable
behavior
and russia leadership will face
unprecedented isolation
this is not a question of blocks
this is not a question of diplomatic
power games
it's a matter of life and death
it's about the future of our global
community
and we will stand united with our
transatlantic partners
and with all european nations in
defending this position
we start united
in saying that no violence and
destruction
has means to obtain political gains
we the european union remain the
stronger group of nations in the world
and this should not be underestimated
more immediately
we will be designing
urgent assistance to ukraine
in this dire situation
we will also be active in supporting
evacuations operations
including of our own staff in zones
affected by this russian attack
the european union together with
transatlantic and like-minded partners
have made unprecedented efforts to
achieve a diplomatic solution
to the security crisis caused by russia
but russia has not reciprocated
these efforts
and instead
has opted unilaterally for a grave
and premeditated escalation conducting
the war
president putin
needs to stop this
senseless aggression
and today our thoughts
are with the people of ukraine
we will stand with them
and you have just been watching a live
press conference from the european union
from uh from brussels there we just uh
heard from joseph burrell he is the
european union's chief diplomat the
foreign policy chief and just before him
we also heard from the european
commission president uh ursula
lion uh ursula fonda lion saying that
she that the european union will hold
vladimir putin accountable for this what
she described as an unprecedented
act of aggression our brussels bureau
chief alexandre fennamon is with us
alexandra what stood out in those
speeches
for you
i think that listening to those
statements make you once again
understand the gravity of uh this moment
and we heard that uh ozola fondelion was
speaking about what is now the united
european response and of course we can
assume that those measures will be
coordinated with the u.s with the uk
with other partners and
she
said that the european union has already
already prepared sanctions that will be
probably approved later today when the
european leaders are coming together
here in brussels and fonder lion made
clear that they are aiming at targeting
strategically important sectors of
russia's uh industry russia's economy
that they are going to um
to limit
or to to make it impossible for russia
to access the european capital and
financial markets and
that they are also going to impose a ban
on deliverance deliveries of important
technology and i think here we can
expect them to ban the delivery of
semiconductors those important small
chips that are not only in our iphones
but that are also needed by russia for
its military
alexandria i was struck by what
joseph burrell the foreign policy chief
for the european union also said about
assisting with evacuations
there will be a lot of people leaving
ukraine and not just people from the
european union there has been talk of a
possible way of refugees is the european
union prepared for that
i'm not sure whether we are as a
european union already prepared for that
but uh we do know that the neighboring
countries um let's take poland for
example um have been in
introducing measures to be prepared we
can expect of course a lot of uh
people fleeing ukraine uh given the
situation there and uh barrel was also
talking about uh
the isolation that russia is going to be
facing i thought that was
also very interesting um
as well as what ozoola fonda lion said
about the european values
democracy freedom
values that the european union stands
for and values that they want to protect
alexander thank you for now that was our
brussels bureau chief alexander naaman
and following that from washington is
our correspondent stefan simons uh
stefan i'm sure you were just listening
to uh that speech by the by that uh
press conference actually uh by the
european
union representatives uh underline and
or what uh what did you make of
what
ursula fonda lion was saying about those
sanctions are they being closely
coordinated with what is happening on
washington what are you hearing there
yeah you can bet on it uh that is that
is what ozola fondelion said uh is
exactly exactly what we will similarly
um here tomorrow at 12 noon uh local
time here in washington dc from
president biden he will emphasize the
same make the same points emphasize the
same thing that
the united states will
now throw harsh really the gauntlet at
russia
making it impossible for russia to
access the international international
not just the european but the
international financial market really
make a
target oligarchs and the inner circle
the a wider inner circle
of
vladimir putin's not just
ministers or or others who work with him
and for him but
also the families and and
you know
in a larger circle of all those who are
in the periphery of vladimir putin this
will happen technology transfer she
mentioned this is of course also big oil
exports from russia will be will be
not happening i assume and there's many
many other things the us as well as the
european union in strong and close
coordination have already in the draw
basically to pull out and to present
tomorrow and
make no mistake i think there's even
then no
end in sight if russia is not in any way
or form bulging
that is of course
let's remember that the sanctions and
the talk of sanctions and the
implementation of sanctions just a few
days ago that was a first step and it
should have deterred
at least that was the hope by the
european union and by the americans he
and but by president biden to deter
russia from doing anything that didn't
work so now um that's punishment now is
the
sanctions
will be a face and interface and used as
a tool for punishment
stephen thanks for now of course it's uh
just shy of three in the morning on the
east coast the americans will be waking
up to this uh very soon
stephen simon is our correspondent
washington thank you very much
and just a reminder you are watching
special coverage from dw news live from
berlin we're covering the russian
attack on ukraine russia has indeed
launched a military assault on ukraine
hitting targets across the country u.s
president joe biden has condemned the
attack as unjustified and unprovoked
here in germany chancellor olaf schultz
said it was a terrible day for ukraine
and a dark day for europe russian
president vladimir putin announced the
move in an unscheduled television
address shortly before 6 a.m moscow time
he warned the world that any attempt to
interfere would lead to quote
consequences you have never seen
within minutes explosions were reported
in cities across ukraine including
odessa kharkiv kramatarsk mariopol and
kiev ukrainian leader vladimir zelinsky
said it was a full-scale invasion and
that russia was attacking military
infrastructure throughout the country as
well as border guards he urged citizens
not to panic and to stay indoors
let's bring in dw correspondent nick
conley here we have a team on the ground
in
in
ukraine nick is part of that he is in
the northeast of the country nick tell
us where you are and what's happening
around you
we're traveling through
oblast to arkiv region which is uh the
last region before donbass if you look
kind of west to east connecticut is
ukraine second biggest city i was meant
to be heading to donbass today and left
my train a bit earlier in a small town
where the initial response was one of
kind of days
surprised and kind of shocked i remember
just the first two hours of dawn came
people staring at their phones
discussing this really incredulous after
all these months of build up this is now
actually happening you saw people in
uniforms people can fire brigade other
kind of government emergency services
stocking up on uh coffee cigarettes and
uh sugar getting in jeeps and trucks and
heading east a bit later you saw
ordinary residents kind of coming out
trying to withdraw cash from banks huge
queues outside the bank same outside uh
petrol stations
uh but no panic so far people trying to
make preparations trying to get
potential supplies for people staying
more less calm not raising voices no
conflicts i think this is a country that
has seen warfare for the past eight
years in donbass and so people are as
best they can be prepared although this
is obviously seemingly a russian
inversion on the scale quite unlike
anything they've seen before
tell us more about that scale nick
because we're having a difficult time
getting an idea of exactly
what has been targeted and what the
state of uh of the development in this
military exercise or this military
attack is we're looking at pictures
right now of flames and smoke rising
above what i'm told is a military
airport what do you know about
what russia is throwing at ukraine right
now
well where i was we
we heard kind of basically shock waves
so probably artillery in the distance
and localizing told me they'd heard
explosions early in the morning from
what they thought was a nearby ukrainian
military air base they assumed those
were russian airstrikes in the substrate
and we've definitely had messages and
reports of similar attacks on ukrainian
military infrastructure on airfields
even right in the west of the country
and abandoned franchises in the border
in poland uh the rationality behind that
is to stop western countries from
sending in
supplies to reinforce ukraine
with um
each country
they're really big different decisions
but it's not just russian things it
seems like troops are also crossing
north
from the south from russia
so this is really a very difficult issue
of ukraine to deal with uh forces
attacking on such huge scale and
touching big
okay
that was uh our correspondent nick
connolly there uh in northeastern
ukraine i was having some trouble
hearing nick i don't know how that was
for our viewers i'm told we have our
chief political editor anyway thank you
for nick if you can still hear me our
chief political editor and mikhail kufna
joins us now from our uh our
parliamentary studios here in berlin
michaela i know you've been following
this uh very closely tell us how germany
has been reacting to the russian attack
on ukraine
well shortly after the news came in that
russia is moving forward and
german chancellor olaf schweitz issued a
twitter statement saying it was a dark
day for europe we expect him to us
potentially speak later we're expecting
the foreign minister to speak in a short
while but the strongest statement um
we've heard so far is from vice
chancellor robert harbeck who's also the
trade and climate minister he's from the
green party
and he went on breakfast television this
morning initially to talk about
generally energy security
but then described what russia is doing
as a war of aggression i quote a war of
aggression on a sovereign state and that
this would change
the not just the peace order in europe
but also relations in the west
transatlantic relations he said that the
west had been too naive is what he used
and that would be including his own
government uh after all all i've sold
only last week tried in what now seems
like a last-ditch attempt to prevent um
vladimir putin from actually moving
ahead but it appears he'd taken this
decision a very long time ago at the
same time a great sense of shock here in
berlin
okay miquila i'm just seeing a
coming across the top of my screen a uh
a flash note saying that the head of the
german
foreign affairs committee in the
bundestag the german parliament has said
that any future gas contracts with
russia would be quote inconceivable
tell us more about how germany is likely
to respond to this in terms of sanctions
together with its european partners
well germany also in
what is seen as a very dramatic move
particularly given the german domestic
context of olaf schweitz
pulled the plug on north stream too
that is the direct pipeline linking
germany and russia russia supplies
a huge chunk of the energy needs
particularly the gas needs of germany a
significant chunk of for europe so
germany and europe is still highly
energy dependent on russia now this
announcement of no future contracts in a
sense
yes that is a significant change in
policy but these are mostly long-term
contracts and the problem europe is
having with russia right now is that
russia is going by the book it's
fulfilling its long-term commitments but
is not going beyond
okay michaela thank you so much for now
that was our chief political editor
makila kufna
you